the history of the saudi state and the
saudi dynasty really becomes interesting
in 1744
in the town of diriyah which is very
close to the modern city of riyadh in
the region of the arabian peninsula
known as the nejd and the is an
important term to know if you're
studying saudi arabia because this
central region of the arabian peninsula
is really the stronghold of the house of
saud
but diria was a successful town in the
early 18th century but the emir of
thiriya muhammad bin saud forges an
alliance with a religious leader
muhammad bin abdul wahab
and that alliance is a very strong one
muhammad bin saud's son marries muhammad
bin abdul
daughter to really seal that alliance
and the wahhabis could be viewed as a
fundamental sect of sunni islam and with
that purest religious fervor this
alliance is very successful over the
next several decades you have the
emirate of theria continuing to grow
first conquering much of the najd and
eastern arabia and then as we go into
the early 19th century as we go into the
early 1800s conquers western saudi
arabia and much of the territory you
would now associate with the modern
saudi state now of note is that they
conquered the western portion of the
arabian peninsula known as the hijas
and the reason why this is significant
you have to remember the context at this
time the ottoman empire with
constantinople as its capital was
nominally in control of most of the
middle east including egypt and the
arabian peninsula but all of a sudden
you have this emirate that starts off in
diriyah and now is able to conquer a big
chunk of the arabian peninsula including
two of the holiest places in all of
islam
on top of that the emir of diriyah and
the wahhabi religious leaders say that
the ruler of the ottoman empire the
sultan mustafa the fourth is not the
valid leader of islam that he is not the
true caliph of islam on top of that in
1802 an estimated 12 000 wahhabis go to
karbala and sack the city they destroy
the shrine of hussein who's a revered
figure amongst shia muslims and they
kill an estimated up to four or five
thousand people and karbala is also
under ottoman control so the ottomans
are not happy about this you have a
fundamentalist sect of islam in the
wahhabis controlling most of the arabian
peninsula including the holiest sites in
all of islam they're saying that the
ottoman rulers the sultan is not the
true caliph of islam and on top of that
they're causing internal strife within
the ottoman empire with the shias by
sacking karbala to make things even more
complicated for the ottomans in egypt
you have another leader who's trying to
exercise his autonomy in muhammad ali
and so the ottomans have a plan why
don't we get muhammad ali to send some
of his troops to focus on the emirate of
theria and so they order muhammad ali to
take on the emirate of theria and this
is what becomes the ottoman wahhabi war
now by the time the war is in full swing
the sultan in constantinople is mahmoud
ii muhammad ali sends his sons who are
eventually successful in taking back
mecca medina and then they lay siege to
the town of theria and they're
eventually able to take it in 1818.
they send the leaders of the house of
saud and the wahhabis to constantinople
including the current emir at the time
abdullah bin saud and just to get a
sense of the family tree up to this
point this is abdullah who is the last
emir of the emirate of thyria who gets
captured by the egyptian forces on
behalf of the ottomans you can see he is
the great grandson of muhammad bin saud
bin saud means muhammad son of saud so
the whole dynasty is named after saud
who was a previous emir of diriyah but
muhammad bin saad is the one who really
formed that alliance with the wahhabis
which enabled the emirate of thyria to
become a major power in the arabian
peninsula eventually taking over most of
the peninsula abdullah was sentenced to
death in constantinople but before he
was beheaded he was forced to listen to
loot music because according to the
wahhabis that was considered sacrilege
while the ottomans had no problem with
it so they were really trying to rub it
in that before you die you're going to
have to do something that you the
wahhabis view as sacrilege but i will
leave you there as we will see the
emirate of theria is the first of three
major saudi states that will each
control most of the arabian peninsula in
the next video we're going to see the
saudi state come back with the emirate
of ned and in blue here you see the
rulers of the emirate of ned's
and then after that we will talk about
the modern kingdom of saudi arabia whose
rulers you see here in green we'll go in
a lot more depth than that but you can
see that they all are descendant from
muhammad bin saud